SCOOP.
>> I WILL.
>> THANK YOU AND GREAT TALKING
WITH YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Sean: SEAN SPICER AUTHOR OF
THE GERALDO SHE.
GERALDO RIVERA AND SOUTH
CAROLINA GOVERNOR HENRY McMASTER
IS WITH US.
AND LET ME START WITH YOU.
THIS IS INTERESTING, IF YOU LOOK
IN THE CASE IN PARTICULAR, IT
WAS A FIRST OFFENSE, AND
LIFETIME SENTENCE FOR A WOMAN
WHO HAD A LOT OF PERMANENT
PROBLEM AND NEEDED MONEY AND GOT
INVOLVED IN DRUGS AND I THINK
THAT THE CASE THAT KIM
KARDASHIAN PUSHED IS A POWERFUL
ONE AND WE NEED TO PAY ATTENTION
TO.
>> I THINK THERE IS IT NO DOUBT
THAT KIM KARDASHIAN'S APPEARANCE
WAS APPROPRIATE.
SURE SEAN SPICER COULD ANSWER
THAT BETTER.
SHE WAS BRINGING ATTENTION TO
A NECESSARY ISSUE AND ONE THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE IS GRAPPLING
WITH THANKS TO THE NEW
LEGISLATION ON SENTENCING
REFORM.
AND A LIFETIME SENTENCE AND NO
PAROLE, SHE DIDN'T MURDER
ANYBODY AND I THINK THAT KIM
KARDASHIAN'S VISIT TO THE WHITE
HOUSE WAS ABSOLUTELY
APPROPRIATE.
SAMANTHA BEE, YOU KNOW THE I
HYPOCRISY.
WHAT WE SHOULD DO IS HAVE THE
THE VICTIMS OF THE INSULT TELL
US WHAT TO DO.
VALERIE JARRET RE71EDED
GRACIOUSLY TO ROSEANNE BARR AND
IVANKA WAS BEYOND GRACIOUS.
WHEN THEY BEG FORGIVENESS.
MAYBE WE GIVE IT.
THAT IS A CHRISTIAN VIEW.
>> Sean: WHAT IS YOUR TAKE.
>> MY SHOCK FAKE.
THERE IS NOTHING IN BOTH OF
THESE CIRCUMSTANCES THERE IS
NOTHING TO SHOCK ME.
JIM ACOSTA TO DECIDE WHAT IS
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO HEAR WHAT IS
DISCUSSED AT WHITE HOUSE?
AND BUT IT IS NOT UP TO THE
MEDIA NEVER MIND JIM ACOSTA TO
DECIDE WHAT IS A VALID ISSUE OR
NOT.
IT IS UP TO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND OTHER ELECTED
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS TO DECIDE
WHAT IS SDRAESZED.
AND EVERY AMERICAN HAS THE RIGHT
TO ADVOCATE GOVERNMENT TO
SUPPORT THEM ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER.
ON THE OTHER ONE SAMANTHA BEE, I
BELIEVE, I MADE A LOT OF
MISTAKES IN THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
I ASKED FOR FORGIVENESS FOR AND
PEOPLE WERE VERY GRACIOUS TO ME.
>> YOU DID NOT MAKE THAT MANY
MISTAKES.
>> THANK YOU, BUT MY POINT IS
THIS.
WHEN PEOPLE SCREW UP AND
APOLOGIZE GIVE THEM FORGIVENESS.
BULLPEN THE DOUBLE STANDARD THAT
EXISTS WHETHER SAMANTHA BEE OR
JOY REED.
AND WHEN THEY MAKE A MISTAKE,
THE LEFT ABSOLVES THEM AND
EXCUSES AND EXPLAINS THEY ARE
NOT THAT BAD AND NO
CONSEQUENCES.
IVANKA IS SO GRACEFUL ABOUT
THIS.
THIS IS IT NOT THE FIRST TIME.
REMEMBER THE FORMER POLITICO
REPORTER IN THE ATLANTIC SAID
A SIMILAR THING.
WHAT WAS THE THING?
SHE DIDN'T MEAN?
?
THE ATTACKS BY THE JOURNALIST
AND PEOPLE ON THE LEFT GET
EXCUSED AND WASHED AWAY EVERY
TIME.
>> Sean: GOOD LUCK FOR YOUR RUN
FOR GOVERNOR IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
IT IS A BEAUTIFUL STATE AND I
HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS DOWN
THERE.
AND I LOOK AT THIS.
I AM LIKE THIS IS NOW AN
ENVIRONMENT.
I READ EVERYBODY'S APOLOGIYS.
AND ROSEANNE APOLOGIZED AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND I SENSE THAT THERE
IS REAL SINCERITY.
2:45 A.M. TWEET AND NOT A GOOD
THING AND I HAVE MY SUSPICIONS
GERALDO KNOWS A THING ABOUT
THAT.
>>IN KNOW VERY WELL.
NO TWEETING AFTER MIDNIGHT.
>> Sean: EVERYBODY WANTS TO
SILENCE VOICES THEY NEVER AGREE
WITH.
I NEVER CALLED FOR CANCELLING OF
A SHOW AND FIRING OF A HOST AND
BILL MAR WANT AND SEAN HANNITY
AND RUSH LIMBAUGH.
WE SAID DON'T FIRE THEM.
>> THESE PEOPLE ARE JUST GONE
CRAZY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS IT ENOMMOUSLY
POP PROSPECT HERE.
IF HE RUN TODAY HE WOULD GET
MORE VOTES AND HAD HIS TWEET WAS
RIGHT.
HE IS SAYING WHAT EVERYBODY IN
SOUTH CAROLINA IS THINKING.
HE'S 100 PERCENT RIGHT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO
THE PEOPLE ON THE LEFT.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS HATRED OF
THE PRESIDENT OR WHAT HE STANDS
FOR.
THEY ARE MAKING FOOMS OF
THEMSELVES.
THEY ARE SO DEEP IN THE TANK
THEY DON'T REALIZE IT AND SHOOT.
THEY WILL APOLOGIZE UNTIL THE
NEXT TIME AND THEN THE NEXT TIME
AND I THINK PEOPLE HAVE JUST HAD
ENOUGH OF IT.
>> Sean: GERALDO, AS MUCH AS I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE EVERYBODY TO
WATCHMENT SHOW,IN HAVE TO HAVE
THEM INVIT ME IN THIS HOME AND
THAT'S HOW YOU GAIN THE
AUDIENCE.  AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE SMART.
WE FEEL WE HAVE TO SILENCE.
>> IN THAT REGARD, REFERENCING
SOMETHING IN THE BEGINNING.
PROGRAM THIS EVENING ABOUT THE
DEEP STATE COMING FOR YOU.
ME.
I WILL BE THERE FIGHTING OFF
THESE PEOPLE.
>> Sean: I HAVE GERALDO IN MY
BUNKER, I AM SAFE.
>> I WONDER WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
LEVEL OF CIVILITY?
IT IS LOW DOWN AND DIRTY NOW.
AND THE CANDIDATE FOR GOVERNOR
IN THE GREAT STATE OF SOUTH
CAROLINA ALLUDED TO IT.
THERE IS REALLY, THE COUNTRY IS
SO DWIELDED AND THE PEOPLE WHO
HATE THE PRESIDENT HATE HIM WITH
SUCH VE HEMINENCE.
AND WHERE DO THEY GET THIS>>
Sean: YOU WANT HIM SUCCEED.
IF HE'S SUCCESSFUL WITH THE
ECONOMY.
LOOK AT NORTH KOREA AND KEEPING
HIS PROMISE AND BECOMING ENERGY
INDEPENDENT AND THAT DACKS CUT.
THAT IS BAD NEWS FOR DEMOCRATS
FOR THEM TO WIN HE HAS TO FALL.
>> THAT IS MELANCOLLIE THAT THEY
ROOT AGAINST THEIR OWN COUNTRY
FOR PARTISAN PERSON.
HAWN>> Sean: LAST WORD.
>> ONE THING ABOUT THE SAMANTHA
BEE IS IT WAS PRETAPED AND THEY
SCRIPTED IT AND STILL WENT AHEAD
OF IT.
THAT IS VASTLY MAKING A STEPPING
IN IT WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT IT.
AND I REALLY THINK THE CASE IS
DIFFERENT THAN A LOT OF THE
OTHER ONES.